hey guys welcome to nerding out the show
where us GameSpot nerds get together to
talk about the shows that we like and
today we're talking about Westworld
season 1 episode 7 honk boy and as
always there's spoilers ahead so please
be careful now let's jump in
okay guys Bernard is a host confirmed
confirmed we called it me and Austin
called it back when we were talking
about by the way guys I'm a producer on
the show I think I called it first I'm
pretty sure that me and Austin put those
notes yes yeah I wrote that doc so uh
anyway cold anyway confirmed Bernard is
a host and it was very hard to watch
that scene just though the what door it
was so I think that Ford is replacing
humans with hosts I don't know if
Bernard was a human before that and he
just replaced him maybe he was like this
you know the scientist or maybe he's
someone else what do you think yeah I
don't think I was much surprised to
everyone here that he was a host but the
way in which they did it was so
effective I thought was really cool but
I yeah I think that Bernard is is Arnold
or at least the recreation of Arnold
that's no longer either he just passed
away or he is somewhere hiding in kind
of on his own went rogue
I also believe that every single time
we've seen Bernard talking to Dolores in
that same basement the basement looks
awfully familiar
that that might be actually Arnold
speaking with Dolores during kind of the
early diagnostics of the prototypes the
first gen hosts I remember when we saw
the photo that Hopkins shared with with
Bernard and said here's a photo of
Arnold and you knows visibly there's
someone missing from that Wow and he
can't see himself so yeah that was you
know glaring to me in terms of that
Bernard is in fact Arnold touching back
on the multiple timeline theory yeah so
I think it's safe to say that Teresa who
met her demise in this episode will be
turned into a host and she will be
working for Ford now so I think that's
gonna happen so maybe it might happen LC
also maybe we don't know poor LC we
didn't see how this episode no moving
yeah
who took her I know who took her but the
real question is one wait yeah about
that yeah someone from the calm
he took her somebody I mean Teresa was
the was was broadcasting so gets
somebody from Delhi oats that took her
because she's now on leave did you guys
notice that part yes
so who took her Delia sleeve yeah yeah
she's now on I said we Bernards like
alright cool yeah she didn't tell me
sausage or it's friggin Arnold Bhatt and
he just made it seem like she's on
vacation he's like I took her you know
she's on vacation yeah whatever I don't
know but the real question here is who
isn't right right like with this Bernard
reveal it could be anyone and I think it
was very telling when they had that
scene with the demonstration and they're
like oh the texta host by the way and
you're like oh snap yeah anyone could be
a host as I was kind of foreshadowing
for the whole Bernard thing so pushing
on my Ford is a host yeah did you see
his face when he was watching that he
was such a host just like yeah yeah it
was amazing acting he's really good at
all those facial expressions let's talk
about forward so he's I don't know he
knows everything he knows everything so
the speech that he gave Austin do you
want to talk about yeah so he gets this
speech you know when he's in the
basement and he's I mean it made me feel
bad for being a human because he [ __ ]
yeah God both suck but I went to the web
site this morning as I always do on
Mondays and I was searching around for
some stuff and then I just started
clicking around on the logo on the main
page yeah it like the page just like
breaks and it starts showing Ford giving
that speech and you know the the screens
cutting just snow and this man
and it's throwing up HTML on the screen
and look through it didn't see anything
and then it caught my attention but that
speech was I mean it was already epic
but I think they're leaning that's
definitely a key there there's something
in it there's there is something there
I'm pretty sure so I also think that
Ford's using all the hostess fuzz you
know that scene where Hector's tied to
the bed yep he could have just you know
got all that information it's like pay
attention to all of Charlotte's
conversations like just do that and so
he was probably doing that with Bernard
so it was like Bernard pay attention to
everything that Teresa says a report
back or whatever and at the end there
says the bug the blood sacrifice the
blood sacrifice at the very end
yeah and he's heard that before in that
conversation exactly I have something
quick reprogrammed it or what what no no
cuz no cuz Charlotte's not not a host I
don't think that Charlotte's a host
because I think Charlotte actually Ryan
thinks Charlotte's a host
do you think Cheryl's hosts I know who
knows at this point no okay
Charlotte was treating okay a human
knocks on the door mm-hmm
to audible sex noises Charlotte opens
the door nude and it's like yo it up
come on in business relationships I
don't care I'm eating give me a can I
have one of your smokes what is
happening world she was treating her
like she was just another host yeah yeah
and I mean at that point I was like oh
three says a host obviously and
Charlotte knows it but then later Teresa
got punched in her face and now she is
definitely a host but still I that was a
weird that was a weird thing Charlotte
says the line none of the people that
work here matter which is like either
corporations really suck or DeLeo snows
that everybody's a [ __ ] host yeah
yeah and corporations suck no Baroness
let's talk about Maeve really quick so
she doesn't freeze when all the other
hosts did so like is it her super
intelligence that's letting her do that
so what would happen if Ford tried to
freeze her
and like is she out of everyone's
control what do you guys think and she's
trying to get out so like what has she
got that she could what happens if she
gets out one yeah that's a good point we
were talking about because I say that
line of your skin everything is baby
here here yeah so if she does get out
what happens she melts yeah
does she Mel she shuts down just like it
yeah I don't think she works outside of
the park or outside of the basement and
the park area you know I think she does
I think I think the entire series is
gonna end with Dolores like actually
getting outside of Westworld and the Sun
hits her face and she's like oh it sucks
out here yeah much more free in seasons
to see this let's talk about her and
William so I think that William still
might be the man in black I think
there's some yeah there's something
there what the way that he's talking
last yeah so yeah he's the man in black
somebody was talking about and has
talked previously about the whole
Dolores Oh to you that talked about yeah
yeah the the Dolores man in black scene
in the in the barn yeah he's not a knife
what the hell do you think I so my
theory is that when when the man in
black is taking Dolores into the barn
he's not doing anything bad he's
actually saying hey remember me I'm
William we were on this journey together
we have sex on the train girl robots
have morning breath that's gross
you all need to brush your teeth I know
there's not a bathroom on that train
yeah I mean maybe something happens that
down the road here with that
relationship though that goes the wrong
way robot baby turns the wrong way not
that way
and then maybe down you know 30 years
later it's it's it's a different
relationship with Dolores who he
seemingly fell in love fell for this
early on and he's still a newcomer to
the park at this point the corporation
did anybody else think the train scene
with the Gatling gun and they send the
horse out and the guys wearing black I
was like oh my god it's just where will
you be comes a man in black I thought
for a second William was like yo you
guys can't hurt ya take everyone out
there yeah same area no I was hoping
that was it but he's still yeah all
right so the next episode is called
trace decay anyone have any theories for
what happens next week based on what the
promo that we saw so what what did
anyone read the definition of trace
decay I'm sure we all did yes two
theories one is a memory itself is
decaying if it's not rear efference tin
your head so every time you think of a
theory it three exercises those synapses
and then the other theory is that the
the path Ingram of Ingram like the
pathway through your brain to that
memory is what diminishes and the memory
stays but you have to reiax s it in the
pathway losses so that's why you can
reacts s childhood memories if a pathway
just randomly goes to it sometimes I
think I personally think that this is
just a rear efference to like the the
robots remembering things I think I
don't think that it's telling us
anything special I think that it's just
robots are going to either start
diminishing like their their memories or
like Bernard for example is going to
start remembering things about being
like an Arnold or something I mean it's
a I mean in that trailer he's like why
did you make me kill her so he's already
I mean he remembers killing two robots
don't remember things that can hurt them
they can't see things that can hurt them
that was my Anthony Hawkins any other
theories for next week or for the coming
three episodes they're left there's only
three we do see Teddy kind of he kind of
see it has a little flashback yeah he
sees something that he's seen before
almost maybe in a different loop
different timeline so I don't
of the referencing that Wow yeah that I
honestly think we're it's gonna come at
the end of the season we're finally
gonna figure out what or who are Arnold
is and we're gonna see so far for does
not had like an adversary that can even
compete without even close I think he's
gonna get surprised like oh this person
can't compete with me and then we're
Thomas yeah he's unstoppable he's like
this the mastermind behind at all where
someone has to where to host things
what is it weird to host or the host for
it's a host were you the first let me
say that yes he was the first one to say
for it's a host also the Bernard thing
join us next week we're gonna talk about
trace decay and for all things nerding
out stay with GameSpot universe
you